hello everyone i'm alana i am joined
today by that's khalif that's awesome
adam and that no that is andy um who i
was playing halo infinite with over the
weekend obviously the test flight slash
beta and i thought that i would get you
guys here today to chat about kind of
what we liked about it what we didn't
like about it how we feel about halo
going forward um we're just hot off the
heels of a very long horror game
conversation so yes the vibes getting
very different right now
i almost left the podcast i was so
scared
um
do you want to start us off like how did
you feel about it what are your general
impressions of the test flight
yeah it was it was actually really
like welcoming and it felt like a really
nice blanket right where you're just
like oh wow i remember all these small
parts of what the halo universe feels
like i remember all these kind of uh uh
parts of the cadence that you wind up
having i think i tweeted something about
like
um unlike other games you understand the
dance and halo
in a very very intimate way of like i
know what i'm going to do in every fight
and to a certain extent you know how
that kind of is going to translate it's
like i'm going to dodge you for a little
bit i see your shield just pop now i
have to switch your weapon and go hit
you with this other kind of uh maneuver
and it felt really good like i think i
had an expectation for
it to continue to be more of what it was
in the previous iterations of what halo
was and this
feels
kind of similar to that but also feels
very much like
a different halo because of the new
weapons the new energy around it um and
the fact that it's like the internet has
changed in a different way
in terms of multiplayer games when
before halo was hot to now where it
where it's landed now so all of those
things combined it just it was so much
fun to be able to get back into that
space and and and get around with some
buddies and have some good times and
roll through and shoot people in the
face with with a little needler again it
feels so good it's so good to begin with
it was hard for me to even cut through
the nostalgia that i was like look at us
it's friday we're playing halo again
just like so happy about doing it yeah
uh andy what were your overall
impressions
i i mean this these are some of the best
weekends i've had in my life yeah like
in such a long time and
i think all of the magic is there and
i think 343 is just primed to have an
extremely successful launch
and like i've i was talking with um snow
bike mike earlier one of our homies who
runs the kind of funny x-cast and he was
mentioning
we were talking about
our expectations for what cam kane what
campaign could be and i'm just like dude
i
this game is already incredible to me i
don't even need the campaign to be that
good i was so worried about multiplayer
and they nailed it and i haven't been in
on a halo since
god knows when like i think halo 3 is
the last halo i played really hard
and then i played some odst i played
some reach and i just kind of like
completely fell off but
this feels like
bungie got a hold of halo again totally
this doesn't feel and i look at the
visual sort of um
the visual design and everything
happening in halo 5 and that looks like
a different company took over right and
yeah this just feels like bungie all the
magic's there
it's incredible it was it's so balanced
the most recent patch from last weekend
really improved a lot of my complaints
that i was having because i was having a
decent amount of issues on pc frame
rate-wise and the most recent patch
totally alleviated all those issues and
god damn what a time yeah i wish it was
just here forever i know yeah it was
that good that even though it's in beta
we're like but can we keep playing
i mean i'm i'm kind of the same in that
uh i didn't play much of four or five
even though i recognized that five's
multiplayer is really good for whatever
reason it just wasn't for me yeah and
people who play it love it and i i
recognize what's there is really good i
like warzone but i just didn't get into
it i think that i don't love the rec
pack system a whole lot but for the most
part i'm like i recognize this is good
but i don't want to play it whereas like
when we go back to what halo used to be
which is what this is i put the most
time multiplayer in reach
uh just because of my age at the time i
like and it feels like that but it's
still yeah it still feels like a visual
upgrade it's it's the identity of halo
but the upgrade that we wanted though i
will count that i totally care about the
campaign i care a lot about how can't be
i mean look to be to be fair like i
would love for that campaign to be
incredible right like of course i want
it to be good but at this point it's
this is already such a win in my mind
yeah i already want to play it and i
would have never guessed that like i'm i
was always excited for halo infinite but
i was never ever super confident and now
these past few flights have just sort of
blown away my expectations how about you
chokes how you feeling overall yeah so
i've been an intense halo fan my entire
life like starting with with halo ce all
the way up to halo 5. i probably put
more time into halo 5 than anybody uh
that i know when it comes to the
multiplayer aspect of it i just i really
am really enjoyed every single part of
that whether it be the the you know uh
pvp multiplayer or the warzone maps or
or what have you uh what i really like
about this one is i do feel like um halo
infinite has kind of captured the weapon
balance of halo 5
in the sense of i feel like i can win
with any weapon of course you have like
a certain advantage based on picking up
whether it be the commando or the br or
what have you but i don't feel like i'm
screwed with an assault rifle which i
really really like um while at the same
time like the movement and the equipment
stuff feels like halo 3 which to many
people was like peak halo multiplayer um
so i i am beyond excited like i uh
and not to be like overly optimistic but
that's just the way i i happen to be i i
could not be more excited for for the
game to come out really really stoked so
i guess we're all really positive across
the board and you bring up something
that i think is totally true is that
like yeah i use the assault rifle and i
never do that in halo multiplayer like
get rid of this trash you know i'm like
interesting a compelling point uh and i
i think that you know even seeing
someone with the gravity hammer the way
that they balance the gravity hem i love
the way it feels i love the sound i
think the sound design across the board
and halo infinite is awesome from what i
played but i'm actually not convinced
that they're going to kill me when you
see someone with a gravity hammer i'm
like no i can make this work which is it
didn't used to be that way it was
definitely a fun thing that i liked
about halo 3 multiplayer was like you
see someone gets the energy sword and
everyone's like oh [ __ ] it's like the
man with the golden gun everyone panics
but not really exciting but yeah they
really i hadn't even thought about it
till you mentioned that that they have
really tweaked it that i feel like no
matter what weapon i actually have on me
at the time with the right maneuvering i
think i can
come out okay a thousand percent yeah
yeah
i don't think you have to worry about
being too overly optimistic i said that
these last two weekends were the best
two weekends of my life
that's a great point
yeah but totally i mean i just think
balance wise everything does feel
incredible and all the sound design is
so meaty and punchy and it just feels
like it always it always hits you at
that right sort of frequency in your
earphones
um
the
a couple of complaints weapon wise i
think that they can kind of tune some of
the
the more rarer weapons like the ravager
is one weapon that every time i say it
i'm like i don't i know what you do but
i've never really felt no i couldn't
figure it out very true yeah
yeah yeah very very yeah exactly and
another weapon like the commando i do
feel like i just want the dmr back i i
want a single shot sort of dmr back the
shock rifle fantastic though i really
enjoy that weapon
um and everything else i i i remember
when we first sort of saw the reveal and
we saw the grappling hook
and immediately i go god damn this is
what haley needed this is going to be
incredible i'm so excited and then a
little hit of sort of a sadness when i
heard that it's a limited pickup item i
went ah why would you do that and now
you get why they did it yeah it's
perfect do you want to talk about what
you managed to do with the grappling
hook candy
oh oh my gosh i mean i i so many cool
things but grappling the banshee at the
end of a match when i was hoping i could
grapple the banshee
it was just perfect timing one of those
like magical video game moments and
i was just i'm still riding that high i
haven't slept since salon it's been like
four days this is still the best day of
my life the best weekend i won't let it
end
yeah it's like when it's your birthday
it's your birthday week you know
that's how i feel right now it did feel
like uh one of those
there are a lot of opportunities to have
halo moments and like i'm totally
ripping off the way that they market the
battlefield series they go battle
fantasies the people at dice it's battle
fantasies where you feel like you have
like you know a big map especially with
big team battle and you feel like you're
playing with toys and you're like oh
look what that person just did what the
hell like there was a point where
somebody that i was playing with
had managed to get on the top of another
person's wasp and stay on top of it and
i didn't even know that was happening
until i saw the video later and i was
like what the [ __ ] like it feels like
the stuff you imagine when you're a kid
and everyone's just super excited and
everything's crazy and like this even
those little moments are still really
satisfying they're like getting kills
from the grave is a thing that i'd
forgotten how much i miss like that's
not something that i feel like happens
anywhere near as frequently in other
games is when you stick someone and then
you get like a double kill from the
grave and you're like yes
a lot of it's just super super
satisfying but yeah i've lost this
battle let me throw this frag right down
below me and you're dead too so good
also also the feeling of a perfect kill
uh which i'm so glad they continued to
have from from halo 5 is such a great
feeling because bringing up the commando
actually i feel like people who are
really good with that gun are going to
be unbeatable
like just nasty like when you have a
perfect kill with a commando it's like
two seconds and the person's dead it's a
crazy gun
anytime i'm so accurate with that yeah
anytime i've ever felt like the commando
is not good
and then i get killed in a millisecond
with it
okay it is a good gun i'm just like i'm
not controlling the recoil ball enough
should i just single tap it yeah it's
right but it is again with a lot of
those weapons i do think that the um
one of my least favorite weapons
definitely the plasma rifle shooting
those three projectiles they're so slow
speed them up a bit but they do pack a
hell of a punch when you are at closer
range you just melt people and it feels
worth it there but when i'm an idiot
trying to hit somebody on the brand new
map from miles away it seems like i just
see
these bullets flying out and they're
just kind of looking at them like all
right i guess i'll just
i'll just step to the side when they
like bachata out of the way
thanks thanks for shooting those
things match is over by the time they
get there yeah the other part of that
that has also been a part of that
equation has been those dynamo grenades
those things are brilliant because one
of the biggest parts about big team
battle especially when you're playing
capture the flag is you gotta slow down
a vehicle and you just throw that thing
down and you can just see people's
sadness just like hit their face when
they're like i was almost free
i almost got out and you're like nah fam
you gotta stay right here
take this weapon and deal with it it was
it was so good learning experience to
see the stuff that they've changed and
one thing that i think is is especially
to infinite's credit is that some people
didn't like halo 5 some people really
like halo 5 but they both seem to like
infinite
everyone seems to be really enjoying it
yeah there definitely are some like some
new weapons that like i was like oh i
need to learn how this works how much is
the grappling hook going to affect
gameplay is this even going to feel like
halo was my concern like andy said i
think having it be timed is a really
good choice it's not as aggressive as
all of your items in reach were people
on armor locking every 10 seconds me i
did that
it's just like a lot a lot more balance
and a lot more exciting when you do pick
something up though it definitely like
had more of a learning curve than i
expected and then it looks the same and
feels the same but there are definitely
some tweaks and one thing that i
definitely noticed was uh some of the
the range for melee seemed to be
different per weapon and i found that a
little bit hard to learn
but learning is good you don't want to
go in and have everything be easy um the
other thing was i feel like if i'm gonna
offer like one criticism that stood out
to me was uh i felt like the vehicles
were a little too flippy yeah yeah they
have loose booties yeah the vehicle the
vehicles flip over too easy just a
little navigating and i had like a
couple of those weird like if i could
get into the code and change a couple of
things it would be like i wish that
there was a sensitivity rating or or you
know slider for your aiming while in a
vehicle because
ghosts feel like they're also really
really too tight in the way that they
turn and shoot oh the first time i drove
a ghost it was terrible i was like oh
what am i doing i was like why i was
like the the boost felt felt awful and
weird and then the the the
warthog also just feels a little bit
loose in in some ways and i was just
like man you need to take that back yeah
tuner figure that out
it reminds me of a bit uh of war zone
where
the enemy of you is a foot tall rock
yeah and i mean call of duty wars where
you know your soldier and call of duty
cannot climb over a foot tall rock and
if you're driving a warthog you're gonna
suddenly do seven somersaults if you
drive over a little rock because it's
gonna it's gonna hit you the wrong way
and
i think
so much of that is due to the fact of
halo's physics system being so
incredible and like i think that's what
makes halo so great to watch and play
um but some of the stuff is a little too
physics-y you know yeah no you're 100
right halo is a physics-based
first-person shooter it totally totally
is in so many ways and they fine-tuned
it so well in so many ways like
i feel like in halo i especially in
those big team battle like that big map
was able to throw a grenade from ages
away and time it right and i feel like
i'm so it's so much harder to do that in
in warzone for example
but yes that is they're absolutely the
reason that the vehicles are too flippy
is that their physics are too accurate
shout out to the skewer
oh so good the skewer is a lot of fun
once you kind of figure out the drop on
it because it
you don't think there's a whole lot of
drop because in those first three maps
there's not a whole lot of range in
those first three maps that they were
being released and suddenly you get that
larger map uh the fourth one i'm
forgetting what it's called um i don't
remember any of their names so um same
yeah the fourth not one [ __ ] it's
definitely bigger
no no but not not even the most recent
one that released the one before that uh
which was the two big spires yeah the
two big expires
okay very like forerunner it looks like
um once we get in that bigger uh
uh area and i got the skewer and i shoot
and i just see it drop like a fortnight
snipe and i'm like holy [ __ ] there's a
lot of kind of draw bullet drop on this
that's kind of good to learn once you
get the hangout it's fantastic and i saw
an incredible clip on tick tock where
a dude was
shooting
vehicles in front of him
with the skewer and the skewer and the
vehicle was hitting enemies behind them
so he was launching the vehicles with
the skewer and like rolling and killing
people that were you know standing on
the other side of them and it's just
it's that's what makes halo halo and the
amount of people in my replies to being
like yeah this looks fun and stuff but
like what's what makes this better than
call of duty or or battlefield or
anything like that and i think it is
just a lot of the the chaos and
playground nature of it
yeah yeah i totally agree i'm not good
at first-person shooters and never have
been and i still have fun whereas like
and i've always loved battlefield but in
call of duty i don't have fun because
it's too fast so like when i'm dying
over and over again i'm not having a
good time whereas halo you can be bad
and still have a great time right and
it's always been that way for me and i
love that
i think i think too i've always liked
the idea of at least in call of duty it
feels this way where if someone sees me
and my back is turned i'm dead right uh
but i love the idea in halo of if you're
good enough which is normally not me
but if you are good enough to be able to
turn around and like outplay that
totally uh that is so cool to me yeah
yeah i love that aspect of it and it's
all about getting back into that rhythm
of like turn back around chuck the nade
at the ground hope that it rolls the
perfect amount and yep and yeah it's i
don't know there's just that that
strategy that goes into it with those
gun fights that our one of our co one of
my co-workers uh nick he
doesn't really play a whole lot of halo
he's kind of just more of the the call
of duty war zone type player yeah and
it was a big change i'm like no no like
it's it's a different rhythm it's a
totally different beast where you have
to understand it's all about the
grenades you are pushing the site you're
pushing sightsee and you were throwing
every [ __ ] thing in your pocket
everything over there and i don't know i
just i missed it i hadn't felt that in
such a long time well i guess since the
first flight started a couple months ago
or whatever sure it was the best weekend
of your life yeah it was absolutely
still going so jokes was there anything
that you particularly didn't like about
it like did you have a takeaway
criticism as someone who is
well we're all really positive but
especially positive so this is uh silly
and i could be totally wrong and maybe
it's just all in my own head but i i got
lucky enough to be able to play the
first flight and then these past two
weekends and i don't know if it's just
me so maybe you guys could confirm if
this is correct or not but i'm pretty
sure like the sprint slide boost is a
little bit slower
i felt like that yeah okay okay yeah all
right you're not wrong i felt that too i
loved i know a lot of competitive halo 5
players or halo players in general we're
not a big fan of the boost and i and i
understand that uh but still in the very
first flight it felt like i could move
across the map quicker if i pressed the
right inputs at the exact right time uh
and in this one it's just a tad slower
so i know it's personal preference but
for me personally
uh i love the fact that if i'm sprinting
and again i press everything at the
exact right time i can move super quick
across the map because i just saw so
many like elite level players
uh use the movement in halo 5 so well
and it was so cool to watch
uh so i kind of wish uh the the boost or
the sprint slide was a little bit
quicker but that's just that's personal
preference for me i didn't feel like the
traversal felt a little bit more like uh
apex than i expected yeah which i i like
but i agree it probably could have been
a little bit tighter i think yeah the
apex sort of call of duty nature takes
over where
you turn a corner and you see three
dudes and they start shooting at you and
you immediately need a retreat and i did
find myself going into that let me let
me sprint slide and suddenly i'm out of
there so damn fast and it feels good and
you feel like it does it's just like all
the pro streamers that do that [ __ ]
i love it
it's just such a minor thing but no
that's totally bad
i found the radar to be uh pretty
redundant but i almost don't feel like
it's a negative because what i did was
just stop looking at it so like
i didn't feel like it was terribly
helpful and i don't know why um but
i think placement like yeah i'm used to
that thing being the upper left corner
yeah maybe the lower left corner just
like threw me way off i was like i'm no
it's not in it's not a line of sight
i'm always kind of trying to look at
what my radar is or because there isn't
like um
uh uh like coordinates or like
directions on your hud when you're
looking at your directions where you're
moving i'm so used to having like north
south and east-west directions on things
now because of all the games i play
where i'm like i can't give people
direction
um i also feel like for pinging people
yeah which i i kept not doing the pings
um i also feel like maybe the detection
radius wasn't wide enough yeah like
maybe it was just
capturing enough on the radar was kind
of the problem so it's
ultimately felt useless which honestly
still not even sure what
what the radar was doing like is it only
when people are crouched
is it back to the old way because i know
some people had some complaints that
they totally changed the way the radar
chain uh felt
and then 343 was gonna kind of
you know backpedal a bit and change some
things about it and i still never fully
knew
what i was exactly seeing on the radar
um
like i i don't know if that messaging
kind of got lost maybe i just need to
read the newsletters a bit more
to fully understand that like oh when
i'm crouched i'm totally safe because i
i
i think i was but i can't even confirm
that i was not being seen on somebody
else's radar
i have no idea which like speaks to how
useless it kind of was to us yeah
yeah i don't i don't really have any
major complaints other than the fact
that the test flight is done like i just
had so much fun it was such a good time
and it feels great i am really bummed
about there being uh no option for
campaign at launch um they're saying
this when we stream i love playing halo
co-op it's been like such a staple of my
life
that like so many good memories
surrounding halo co-op so i think that i
probably i'm worried about spoilers
because this one does seem like it's
returning to the halo law that i do
deeply care about um then i'm hoping i
don't get anything spoiled while we're
waiting for co-op but
and
they're kind of out there already due to
data miners those are really data miners
yeah yeah which i have managed to
completely avoid me too
i've been very long
yeah not even looking anything up but
yeah i heard i heard the same thing
that's one of those weird things of like
being on the inside you're like send me
the code early
before everybody else plays it
please send it to me early i don't want
anything spoiled for me yeah
i do hope though campaign wise like i'm
giddy at the idea of like this talk
about it being somewhat open world
to like yeah the idea of being on your
way to a mission and like there being
like a camp of covenant or brutes or
whoever and if you clear out this camp
you get like this uh cool addition to
your battle rifle or something i think
it'll be like destiny so excited yeah
yeah just like it was an event go check
out the other i mean i i love so bad
again with how physics based uh the
engine is it just it's gonna feel like
first person breath of the wild for me
to go to campsites to know that there's
two canisters there and there's a bunch
of brutes there and if i throw one thing
the explosion's gonna be gigantic yeah
the quarks it's gonna be a bunch of like
different cortana ais
i love those organic moments that can
happen because of how playgroundy
everything in this game is totally i
feel like i think that we we should talk
about before we we wrap this up uh as
much as i love this enthusiastic halo
conversation um how did you guys feel
about cross play uh i played entirely on
pc and same as you and he did have a
bunch of frame rate drops to begin with
that seemed to get even out by the end
um eventually swapped a controller just
because i was having trouble like
remembering certain things like i kept
pressing them melee instead of throwing
grenades on the way the keyboard uh was
mapped um and i was like i don't want to
spend the time of this test flight to
fix any of this because we're running
out of time so i just swap to a
controller um i feel like the the fov
like especially seems like it is very
much designed with consoles in mind and
it seems like people who were playing on
console have the smoother experience i
think you said you were right chucks you
you played unconscious actually didn't
you as well i played on both i think
played on both yeah oh nice and
performance was really stable across the
board yeah i had no problems with it in
terms of
performance it felt really smooth
because i play on the control arm both
yeah and it felt really really good on
on both both versions of it and and it
was nice to be able to just like look at
the only thing that was a problem was
like actually pulling in friends to
games for stuff was like what list are
you on are you on my steam list
windows g and that's not working and
then i'm trying to get you in i'm like
you know
actually
easiest for the xbox side of things for
sure which like master chief collection
is still such a mess
it's still a mess yeah but i found
myself just having a shift tab the whole
time and find people on steam that were
hidden on xbox for whatever reason you
know like yeah that was a whole thing um
a whole issue but that feels like a beta
issue yeah yeah exactly perform now i
mean the thing with like cross play i
just feel like cross play is always very
hit or miss anyway so
i'm not trying to downplay the issues
it's just like any any time i've
encountered a crossplay issue on any
game i'm just kind of used to it by now
yeah where it's like oh my nat type uh
i'm i'm restricted on the or a moderate
nat type here so i can't join you like
i'm just kind of used to that oh for
sure but in terms of like cross play in
terms of like
competitive gameplay like chugs did you
feel like you were significantly
disadvantaged against people who might
have been on mouse and keyboard yeah i
mean i i think it's fair to say uh
fortunately for me is uh i've never been
like a super competitive uh halo player
in the sense of like even when i play
multiplayer it's always been uh just
like casually playing through whether
you're having a good time me too exactly
whether it be slayer or btb or whatever
uh but yeah i could understand why you
know people would feel like oh that's
not really fair however i think you can
enable or disable crossplay
i believe that's the plan
yeah yeah which does
at the end of the day for me at least
the style of gamer that i am i get
excited at the idea of more people
having more of a chance to play halo
because halo is my all-time favorite fps
franchise so i'm all about it and it
being freedom players
players
i'll play with all of you we'll have a
great time but i i do feel like so i
think they said that
ranked is restricted based on your input
so that makes sense
um i never touch ranked in halo either
like you said i'm here to have a good
time
that's it i'm not gonna promise anything
um but i think there were some issues um
just based on the small amount of time
that i played on controller with the
sensitivity settings like i would have
liked to have more options um sure but
otherwise like yeah i felt like
i didn't see a tremendous amount of
complaints for pc versus controller it
seemed to work pretty well and i think
that that's part of the balance of halo
and i i wonder if kind of you know how
now you get that flash
um if someone's aiming at you with a
sniper yes
i was like
i i can understand a few reasons for
that i don't think i love that decision
at first i was like this is helpful and
then i was like this is too easy um and
i feel like maybe that was like part of
trying to balance that landscape out i'm
not sure warzone yeah yeah totally yep
yeah but i i feel like that
originally in halo you used to just be
able to see
the uh like the transfer trails yeah
sniper trails so i feel like i i'm maybe
i'm just used to that i don't play call
of duty like i said it's a bad time for
me i don't have i mean maybe that's due
to the fact that it's
you know you do kind of get that player
outline but people can kind of just look
like whatever now and that was it was
always the worst playing red team in
blood golds because they would blend in
with the red
oh yeah
but now like i don't know i feel like
the sniper glint is probably just
something that
is gonna feel weird for halo fans that
never really played any of their any of
the other franchises or whatever but i
do think that it is kind of necessary
because when i see it i
immediately run and i just that that's
ingrained in my brain to be like peace
out i'm not gonna peak this because it's
a one shot and i'm dead you know
that makes sense yeah i mean it's it's
something that i probably just need to
get used to for sure um i mean i've
played a lot of battlefield but that's
that's me too my battlefield brain is
like [ __ ] run because i feel for me is
the ultimate like i got shot from i
don't know where so yeah but i love that
about battlefield that's my favorite
like i love it because you're like he's
on that bill i didn't even know you
could get up there like yeah
it's been a great week for first person
shooters in general no doubt um to close
this out how did you guys feel about the
the cosmetics and like what it seems
like they've lined up for the battle
pass and all of our
upgrades like it obviously is a
free-to-play game so they want you to
buy this stuff and my first impression
was like oh my god there's so much
yeah i i mean just getting a little
taste of the kind of color scheme stuff
was really really nice to be able to see
some of that kind of come through in the
flight
and it's going to be one of those things
where i didn't think that it was gonna
be something i cared that much about but
then i remembered going back and i was
like there's gonna be a hayabusa helmet
in here at some point and i'm gonna have
to go grind for that i will do whatever
i need to do to get that thing and then
they're gonna probably have those
versions where they have the like
limited time like you need to play this
amount to get your flaming skull or any
of that kind of stuff i'm like oh i
remember that and then getting everybody
together to like to go run to get that
thing done i was like oh this is going
to be so much just so much fun just
being able to go back and like run
through battle passes and earn stuff now
it's going to be so good yeah i i am
such a sucker for that stuff like halo 5
i unlocked everything that i possibly
could and i loved the entire grinding
process like i would get so excited i'm
like okay i just need to play like two
more hours that i can maybe unlock this
really cool helmet or with mcc it's the
same thing where i'm like okay i just
need to you know unlock these
achievements and then i'll get these
points so i could use that to buy this
armor set or whatever it is uh so i'm
stoked like i
even in the uh the flight i went the
whole way through and got like the final
armor coding and i could not have been
more excited like i was like look how
cool i look yeah i i ended up being
really really impressed at first i was
like this is too much and by the end i
was like okay this is this is cool it
all still looks like it fits in halo
even though there is a ton
of variety and then again i just got
nostalgia of like remembering people in
halo 3
who had cool lightning helmets and i was
like how did they get that and like you
know someone's ranked based on the
helmet they were wearing like it was so
much fun so i feel like overall
i love the idea of the shaders i just
hope that they opened it up a bit more
in the way that destiny did early on
where you were sort of just you were
limited to the one shader and then
eventually they open it up to where you
could put shaders on multiple different
items and stuff like that and i hope
that we see that with halo because i
i love i love the idea of shaders i love
how they are implemented and now this
piece is that color i just i don't know
there's something so cool about that but
i would love to
you know maybe i only want my helmet to
have that one multicolored trader and
everything else be like all black or all
blue or something like that i i kind of
hope that uh that they go that extra
step but you'll have to delay it another
year probably
because once you open that like once you
open that hornet's nest like pandora's
box horde's nest what's the word i'm
looking forward to most of them either
order there's a lot of hornets in that
pandora's box
once you yeah once you open that up
you know you're just it's a can of worms
as well
you can go [ __ ] yourself
get out
i'm done
all three
i will say this is a really stupid
cosmetic complaint um not to do with uh
armor but uh
the grenade physics and gravity hammer
no longer moves dead bodies
the grenade physics don't have as much
complaint
such a minor thing that i was like but i
missed
you another complaint what about the
player collision a lot of people having
issues with that oh what is oh yeah you
can't run into there's no player
collision you just run through each
other yeah no way i don't think i've
ever tried huh yeah
that's just something i never really
noticed but a lot of the hardcores out
there were like yeah like there's just
even more chaos that can happen
when i can jump on your head and then i
can use that to go yeah to whatever spot
or whatever you know how else are you
gonna get those skulls you know maybe
that was
a beta thing that seems very strange
the other thing was the jet the
jacking radius was like way too big it
felt like you could grab you can take
somebody off a vehicle from super far
away it felt like even if you weren't
using the grapple hook to kind of get
towards them like somebody snagged me
and i was like i was near you i wasn't
near you where did you come from to like
take me off this turn like when they
take your tail and fall guys like all
the knicks
yeah i wasn't sure what if the radius
was different for different vehicles as
well but again that's the thing that i
feel like it's more about e-learning
that i'm going to have fun figuring that
out
and for
anybody listening that wasn't able to
play i think one of their main concern
is
seeing all these clips with the
grappling hook and thinking that
vehicles are now rendered useless and
they're not but
it is still balanced incredibly well
the only thing now is you don't feel
absolutely useless and
like you're just kind of looking up a
hill when everybody has the [ __ ]
vehicles and you're just kind of stuck
with nothing that's always that always
felt so helpless when you were you know
back in the old days and i think now
they just added an extra little thing to
kind of help alleviate that along with
the skewer um but yeah i think it still
feels incredibly balanced like i was i
agree i was still able to go like 21-5
from a [ __ ] just turret on a warthog
one uh one of those big team battle
games so it's still extremely balanced i
think you're not they're not useless at
all the grappling hook also like you
have to aim it very well to get onto a
vehicle from what i felt at least like
that you have to be pretty precise with
that and i think if you're seeing a lot
of clips of it it's because when it does
happen it's so cool
not because it happens all the time like
it didn't happen every match
um it and it is super neat but um
yeah i mean i i'm very excited about it
glad you guys had a good time it was
very fun playing with all of you um
yeah
khalif did you have any closing thoughts
and also where can people find you
i'm just very excited for more of it
that's the first time in a long time
that i've been in a beta where the
servers were about to shut down and
people were jamming on the button to get
that one last game in yeah and cheering
we were like we got another game in i
can't believe the servers are actually
supposed to be off we got another game
and oh my god it's so great um so i'm
just extremely excited for it i'm hyped
as heck for it um and you can check out
more conversations about that when it
drops and everything else with the work
that i do over at spawn on me uh we drop
our show every friday uh every week uh
in the live show that's twitch.tv slash
phone i mean you can go check out more
cool stuff that we do over there when we
have conversations around video games uh
culture all the things that people don't
want to talk about on the internet and
video games we talk about so you get a
chance to come check out the show then
thank you uh andy how about you
closing thoughts slash welcome people
posing thoughts i felt such a relief
when i saw the tweet from i forget who i
think was david ellis actually from 343
that said
uh only a couple hours left in this in
this flight and i was like that means
there's another flight i just got so
excited knowing that we're gonna get
another one in the future so i'm pretty
stoked about that uh and you can find
all of our podcasts uh kind of funny
games on twitch and youtube that's kind
of funny games and then my own twitch
channel uh andy cortez
i did want to mention i think that david
ellis is also the one who tweeted about
the time zones i saw some complaints and
it's like well humans have to to
work on weekends to keep this stuff up
so they were like we're aware of that
we'll try to balance it better in the
future but it also does require real
people working real hours to we'll get
qa right on that
it's qa's problem uh chucks how about
you closing thoughts slash where can
people find you yeah same thing uh just
beyond excited for this game uh again
from halo ce to halo 5 to the upcoming
halo infinite uh i'm stoked i really do
feel like this could be the game
that gets a bunch of people who either
used to be into halo uh or haven't tried
it before uh this might be the game that
grabs a lot of people i i really really
do feel that way just playing the the
flight or the beta just felt super
special uh and same thing i'm so sad
that it's over but
but i can't wait for the game to come
out uh i stream halo quite a bit uh so
you can find me twitch.tv the chugs we
play a bunch of different stuff on there
specifically halo so yeah that's where
you can find me cool thank you all for
joining me and thank you everybody for
watching see you next time
bye